we found an image though of um it's of
the school newspaper that interviewed
you and I I love I think a good comedian
that's what you said should be able to
relate to the audience and talk about
things in a natural way like you just
did so you still believe this you're
still rolling with you're rocking with
this where did you find
that last night I snuck into your house
I'm kidding no wait so yo I don't even
have this that's crazy I said that
yeah and but you know what I think is
beautiful it's somebody in this audience
including myself needed to hear what you
just said but I think I think what's
incredible is you said this a long time
ago but you're still living that same
like truth you're still living those
same words which is kind of incredible
you so we're going to be best friends
that's be my best friend okay that's
that's is just mies o um do you remember
that that moment though like being a
part it was couldn't have been easy the
whole time you had to bomb once
right
you're did did I just over you did I
just over you I was like I didn't even
mean to like no I just think it's a
beautiful thing
how it's a beautiful thing like how how
you know you find these things from like
when you were younger in that dreamer
and then you didn't lose that that
Essence is still in you that's
awesome we're going to get you a photo
copy of this
okay I'm going to have it like
a
why are you so moved right now I need to
know exactly why cuz I didn't think I
was that
smart you are not then not then I was a
wreck I was a mess maybe you thought you
maybe you a 19y old mess we all were
what 19-year-old has their together like
nobody knows 19 you can't air any of
that Lord have mercy I came my here to
be beautiful
I okay wait we're going to get touched
up in a commercial break Leslie's book
my makeup girl Leslie
lo lo mine's glow glow that's so funny
Leslie's book is called Leslie bleeping
Dron it's up now you got to go get a
change your
[Music]
life
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home